a médica especialista é hematologia
clínica no serviço de hematologia
clínica do centro hospitalar e
universitário de coimbra onde dirige a
unidade de transplante de medula óssea
caterina giraudo de trabalho para
inverter o prognóstico fetal de algumas
doenças é o virou voz off e bozó fiz
algumas das funções que eu tenho mas eu
não sou que nem com médica nem com o
investigador nem cometer desatinos
universitária guardo a nada disse eu sou
apenas por conhecer suas seccionais que
o feijão melancia
algumas dessas pessoas suas que um dia
poderão aquilo que é provavelmente o bem
mais valioso que nós temos é nossa saúde
suas que um dia tiveram diagnóstico khan
pessoas que ainda pior não tinham
diagnóstico é ter um diagnóstico técnico
com um prognóstico favorável a todas as
suas fases vão conhecer os que vieram
este nosso e conseguir montar quanto com
todas as forças coragem determinação e
todas estas pessoas todos os dias uma
fonte de inspiração e com que tem sempre
aprendi muito
já agora aqui neste momento
o suas é que podem dizer que têm e saúde
levantei o braço favor é grande maioria
ou seja vocês têm é muito provavelmente
um dos melhores motivos no mundo
prestarem muito feliz mas pode dizer a
nós o fisco não tem emprego mas deixam
procurar quando já trouxe da procura em
outras não e quando a gente o país
procura no estrangeiro nem contra a nato
área de formação entre amplia a sua
fundação ao invés de informação abrir
seus melhores profissionais podem dizer
também a nível e não sinto isso porque
não têm telemóvel topo gana então
comprar mais barato também não teve pra
comprar mais barato então com o
telemóvel mil
a comunicação entre as pessoas não
nasceu com os telemóveis
muito antes de existirem as pessoas se
comunicavam ea verdade é que é preciso
uma coisa com as pessoas que ficaram
excitados comunicado
e agora eu vou explicar por que vocês
têm tantos motivos para se sentirem tão
felizes por terem a vossa sul
vamos conhecer andré ilha olá a todos o
andré tem 25 anos e vence o quer por
duas vezes na história da amiga são o
campo começa em 2009 com nenê é preciso
complicar-nos com final feliz
em 2010 o diagnóstico que assombrou
minha família fez novamente parte da
nossa vida mas desta vez eu compro
tenista é quando teve os primeiros
sintomas o bloco tenha tinha cancro no
entanto até o diagnóstico final mantendo
a esperança que não fosse ou que tivesse
cura vai ser confirmar a patologia um
informador ótica e numa altura em que
estava a terminar a tese na sepultura
foi ultrapassar esta situação é e vou
ganhar a batalha inicial certamente se
terminar e teses e se criou uma pausa na
resposta vida normal de uma rapariga de
21 mais olha vai a shows não acham que
isto se sentirem muito suíço andré viu é
sumaré ter um diagnóstico um cancro ela
própria um ano depois teve o mesmo
diagnóstico e acho que a jovem que vocês
acabaram de conhecer e ver se o carro
por duas vezes
em seguida da doença e teve novamente
fazer tratamento e fez um transplante
ela o ginete está a preparar a sua tese
de mestrado que exatamente sobre
aspectos um é quais relacionados com o
informado aqui conhecer agora uma outra
instituição fato o pessimismo domina a
vida das pessoas que tenham um
diagnóstico da doença grave e vamos ver
com estratégias é que as pessoas
utilizam para inverter esse mesmo
pessimismo e vamos agora quer dizer que
a doença volvo números mas mais como
ajudar a família com as pessoas pela
empresa desde o início como uma apoiada
sempre qualquer qualquer problema humano
faz ao funaná positivo e pensar que tudo
o que melhor fizeram com que idade e
quando pensava que estava ao meu lado e
em reparar que ir por aí que o final
mais do que eu
e enquanto este facto força nessas
pessoas e na família enix que sempre
caminharam no lado apesar de ser um
processo que teria que ser eu a
percorrer já hoje que falamos da
universal e de facto nós temos muitos
jovens que se encaixam falta universal
porque os estúdios da globo filhos na
escola é uma chatice porque os
professores são também bursite esta
jovem eo jovem anterior falou com manuel
terminaram a sua licenciatura no tempo
previsto depois do diagnóstico de uma
doença grave
o manual fiz dez câmeras que faltavam no
tempo previsto
andré e terminou a sua testa
licenciatura qual é um jovem que tem
mundo família come casa que vive um país
quando não há guerra diz que não tem
diversão pra estudar acham isto é
aceitável
a motivação está na frente de deus não
houve porque não querem então tem os
chatos
entre os dentes abrir rapidamente estas
pessoas sim é que é muito difícil
encontrar motivação para avançarem com a
sua vida e conseguiram encontrar o
suspeito é um jovem hoje descer com
todas as condições que não tem motivação
por favor abra os olhos
o vazio o vazio porque efetivamente uma
vez e graf está associada é grande tempo
de espera é só esperar aguardar o
tratamento de quimioterapia ou
radioterapia os consultas aos
internamente ou então como foi o caso
várias destas pessoas possível já que
vão conhecer durante o transporte e
vieram longos períodos de isolamento e
como é que preenche do brasil como é que
tiver o vazio associado a esse
isolamento trabalho
o deixe isso aí faz o transplante foi a
fase mais complicada de tudo o exame por
si um islamita lodra antonis foi um dos
momentos mais difíceis e recanto que o
tocar e falar com as pessoas que
gostamos é o melhor que temos é todos os
dias eram uma luta para ainda ter um
estado emocional do brasil e tentar sair
do pessimismo pra ainda muitas são
física natural deste processo
é claro que os doentes não vivem no meio
de outro carro sozinhos
existem vários movimentos aliados e como
é que conseguem inverter isso o próprio
nós tipo o negativo
uma criança pequena é próxima do ente
que nós vamos conhecer e lídia time
neste momento 55 anos e teve a 14 anos
detido num canto do assim chamado minha
alma múltiplo ela própria quanto o
diagnóstico nem sabia o que era essa
doença e tem um filho com dois antes
este problema ainda mais aguda
vou falar uma família monoparental e ele
vivia sozinha com a criança que hoje tem
16 anos e um jovem saudava em 15 seu eu
não vou chegar as suas angústias que
espera um filho
eu vim sozinho o filho ainda precisa de
coisa não se corre no santos porém perto
sempre chega sozinha pessoa compre nato
é enquanto os eua pensam ser falta
infantil parecer não é que eu achei meu
filho que é importante para feitas
quando eu cheguei o magistério
eu percebo é que eu te falar com ela
explicar 19 tratamento sempre foi essa
foi a nossa toda sua vida é ter ao seu
alcance não tiver muito cuidado dos
filhos
nessa altura tem certa de 15 7% nos
ferros no fim
15 ele é não aconselho a insônia
o esporte sempre é também não queremos
pagar em pé
não vi que não sei a frente nunca
necessitou
eu acho que num nível caps natura eu
tinha que entrar na sala de aula como eu
gosto é muito grande nessa altura já era
um perigoso você fica a sensação de que
eu esteja aqui eu tenho cachorro eu
deixar o espanhol tentará ficar na
história ligar quando enfim vai
funcionar foi natural
esse colchão casa conseguiram entrar em
consenso cidade agora não desconhecer o
otávio que também tentou inverter se o
prognóstico negativo de ter feito uma
informação aqui não é possível em 2004
suficientemente mau humor deus me ajuda
dois anos depois quando o primeiro
diagnóstico a esposa estava grávida do
segundo filho a segunda filha aliás que
tinha já um filho com cinco anos
vamos ver a estratégia que utilizo
partida complicada e que organizaria a
menina no hospital então porque é que o
processo é um processo que a gente tinha
acesso e é o médico lhe disse
diretamente e indiretamente fiquei
sozinho em casa e foi alguns vídeo teria
seu cliente era vida ela trazia o
repórter - eu tiver eu queria ter um
filho
êêê resolvi fazer com que o senhor fez
por vica quer se esforçar e fazer eu
jogo brincar com os filhos não chega já
estava com sexo francisco ecoway eu vim
aqui o canto e bater este já não querem
um espírito uma forma de estar na vida
parece e ela está sendo grande e eu
gostei de jogo sempre nisso eu não sei
que o são gonçalo nos textos e não pode
brincar nas ruas embora às vezes é uma
doença não seja efetivamente quando está
em uma doença oncológica número exato de
khost é uma das conseqüências possíveis
infelizmente prováveis de facto astro
idade mas até estas podem investir
vamos ver como é que o manoel ea esposa
e inverteram esta complicação dos
tratamentos em a cantora
temos um vídeo com três anos o qual é o
segredo da nossa casa em brasília e como
é que um médico riaz a sua própria
doença
como é que um médico e verso do papel em
um dia e meio de controle do evento uma
mãe é médica tardiamente e como é que
concilia esta situação doença com a sua
vida profissional
vamos ver se os quatro vídeos rápido o
primeiro é de ano dia ter fumado no
braço foi investigada e chegou à
conclusão que tinha um ser como foi dito
no início que havia a possibilidade de
adquirir uma cirurgia na finlândia
computação domingo
infelizmente a boa resposta aos
tratamentos e evito esta cirurgia
radical de nós tipo t1 pátria minha vida
tenho alguém quer uma fase da minha vida
e portanto
dessa fase fariam para pessoas que vão
acompanhar sempre
não não queria expor pra lá pra fora
lixo feminino amador algumas coisas pra
minha família pra não conseguiria vida
profissional com o socorro a minha vida
pessoal manteve-se mas o profissional
ficar e se ele vai realmente foram eram
juvenis sobre todos os testes e
sobretudo os meus limites é que não
tenha trazido não irá
queres que eu mais que mais gostava que
era as conversas costumam sobre as
pessoas costumam as coisas costumam
tentar conter o problema é que quando eu
conseguia e ao suíço do corpo só têm
agora vamos conhecer a história de outro
colega meu onu que há cerca de dez anos
é porque sentia cansada e vi umas mechas
na terra se fazer análises foi para casa
e entre de um colega depois por fumaça e
viver o resultado seria que o normal
como maria em casa 4 a 1 em casa
eu consegui foi encontradas também teve
um dia mau para um monitor do rio vai
dormir um pouquinho vamos ver se no
melhor concelho para morrido e conseguir
ter coisas para fazer
todavia o mesmo em londrina
eu realmente não gosto sob sua
assinatura
as pessoas usam o seu lugar deve ser
assim melhor não falar do filme falará
mais satisfeito não falar da orelha
são cidades que os fizeram um bom
exemplo é não tinha completado em um
chat trabalhado nessa hora eu te conheço
efe
em 2009 perdeu uma filha na forma súbita
e inesperada os meios de diagnóstico do
irmão
os meses depois fiz o diagnóstico
informar agressivo e preciso de fazer
quimioterapia
é impressão minha vida do dia-a-dia
procurei sempre vamos fazê lo sem
alterar nada e um desempenho e trabalhar
com com prazer com o moço não aprendem
nada nunca nunca deixei de trabalhar
procurava cantar fazer caminhadas não me
tenha minha prática desportiva que ela
gerava os amigos tinham já faça também
hoje em dia o turismo é minha é deles
que minha história clínica tona porque o
conceito dos quatro anos desde o
nascimento da filha maria na t
esse é o nó crónica outras plantas
obrigações todos e multas quanto outras
plantas de operações de cimento informa
o tratamento com sucesso no fundo é essa
minha experiência para dar a ele e
pronto seu exemplo como está instruída a
dia e muitas vezes não entender esta
frase nós temos fez graça com a frente é
passar na sua frente uma olhar para trás
em colaborar porque tenho 58 cm sem
viver todas estas pessoas partilharam
comigo e convosco estas vivências as
suas experiências abriram inscrição e
falaram dessa forma absolutamente direta
objetiva sem qualquer tabu sem qualquer
preconceito cresce nosso maior respeito
é nossa melhor direção e eu agradeço e
mesmo porque sei que um dia numa destas
auto-estradas da informação
havíamos nos encontrado em um dia estar
fisicamente mas eu sinceramente não
interessa se é aquele espaço e ea forma
como foram ouvidos os seus testemunhos
seja próximo de nós porque a com alguém
gostar do meu nome da saúde do brasil
com 80 lojas não desistam dos votos
sangue
o meu estuário doença que afetou no
organismo e poder ajudar muitas pessoas
em inverter os seus prognósticos
muito obrigada pela vossa atenção de seu
filho